hi Farrah nose founder Elizabeth Holmes
told CBS this morning in 2015 how she
would transform blood tests by using
just drops of blood pricked from a
finger to get fast low-cost test results
for everything from cholesterol to
cancer she also convinced investors to
sink hundreds of millions of dollars
into the company I'm sitting here with
John Kerry roux of the Wall Street
Journal who first broke this story and
has now written a book called bad blood
first of all let's talk about Elizabeth
Holmes she started this company at what
age 19 she dropped out of Stanford in
the middle of her sophomore year and
originally launched it as a real time
cures and then changed the name to
tharros and that's the combination of
the words therapy and diagnosis everyone
I talked to on this story for 6 minutes
says it's a great idea right the blood
testing industry is ripe for disruption
it is a great idea I mean people it's
true what Elizabeth said at the height
of her fame a few years ago people don't
like to go get their blood tested they
don't like the needle they don't like it
they don't like the fact that you have
five tubes of blood that have to be you
know taken and and people as a result
avoid getting their blood drawn and and
it probably does result in fewer timely
diagnosis she was able to convince a lot
of powerful people to get behind her
George P Shultz the former Secretary of
State also former Secretary of Labor so
well-regarded he was one of the first to
buy in absolutely larger-than-life
figure crafted the Reagan
administration's foreign policy many
people credit him with winning the Cold
War and he was a key figure in this
Thera know saga because Elizabeth met
him in 2011 and as I understand it mr.
Shultz is passionate about science and
she really wowed him with her vision and
soon after meeting her joined her board
and and became her biggest champion and
then introduced her to his friends from
the Hoover Institution Henry Kissinger
Sam Nunn all these aging former
statesmen who by the way had no
background in medicine and
didn't know anything about laboratory
science in fact you call it one of the
most illustrious corporate boards in
American history right it was a an
incredibly prestigious board and in fact
one of the investors in thier notes was
this hedge fund mist in San Francisco
that invested almost a hundred million
in early 2014 and when it's two top guys
went to theron o--'s to meet with
Elizabeth and sunny her her boyfriend
who was the number two executives they
were impressed with the claims that
Elizabeth and Sonny made and the charts
of data and everything in the financial
projections but they were also wowed by
the board the board you know was part of
what sold them on the company and it
didn't occur to them that a start-up
with such a prestigious board that
anything could be going wrong there
mm-hmm
she's been charged by the SEC and if you
look at those documents they accuse her
of an elaborate years-long fraud in fact
they called it massive fraud right where
where was some of this fraud where did
we see it well the unethical behavior as
I explained in my book started at an
early stage in 2006 she fired her CFO
when he confronted her about these fake
demos that they were doing for
prospective investors but where this
really became the big big fraud is when
the bright red line was crossed in the
fall of 2013 of going into Walgreens
stores and offering the Fairness
fingerstick tests in Walgreens stores in
Palo Alto and in the Phoenix area
because then you cross over into
affecting patient health I mean these
are real patients real lives that that
were at stake we'll get to that in just
a moment but I want to talk about
Elizabeth Holmes herself blonde
blue-eyed brilliant a brilliant heir by
essentially 2013 a company had already
raised about 700 million dollars and her
voice she had this very deep voice was
that affected yeah that was part of the
Act as well one of the anecdotes in the
book is that a new employee met with her
in 2011 and it was at the end of a long
day
she was getting up from her chair and
expressed excitement that he had joined
the company and she forgot to put on the
baritone for a moment and slipped into
her more natural sounding young woman's
voice and at that point it dawned on him
that that [ __ ] was a put-on
yeah it's so funny cuz everybody who
watched the 60 minutes piece again said
oh my gosh her voice is so unusual this
it's so deep but I wonder if that was
part of her way in a male-dominated
Silicon Valley of trying to and also in
the Investor world of trying to you know
portray sort of importance or whatever
was I mean there was this whole kind of
Mythology you've used that word cult
around her and I keep thinking - you
know we've had Steve Jobs we've had Mark
Zuckerberg we've had Bill Gates all men
who dropped out of Ivy League schools
like she did and people were rooting for
a woman to succeed in Silicon Valley
right we're rooting for Elizabeth Holmes
right there was a yearning for a
billionaire female startup founder I
mean there'd been other women in Silicon
Valley in recent years who risen to fame
like Marissa Mayer Sheryl Sandberg at
Facebook but they hadn't created the
companies they were the the hired help
yeah in a way and Elizabeth Holmes was
going to be the first female billionaire
founder and and people really wanted her
to succeed for that reason in part and
then what you say about Silicon Valley
is very true it's it's really
overwhelmingly a man's world and I think
she put on the voice the deeper voice to
be taken seriously and in a way I can
understand that so we talked about this
you know finger prick right where you
could get a couple drops drops of blood
the proprietary technology was that she
had developed was essentially the Edison
there was later a mini lab there at
Ford's of it but it was supposed to be
the iPod of healthcare right like in the
future someday we'll be sitting in your
office you can bring blood in there at
home even beautiful Wi-Fi to your doctor
your doctor said your cholesterol levels
look too high I'm gonna prescribe some
more lipids or whatever so so good idea
they couldn't ever get this machine to
work no just rudimentary in design right
right so that there were three
iterations basically the technology
if you count the fact that it first she
had this vision for this arm patch which
was really science fiction and then the
second one was this microfluidic device
that was like the size of a toaster they
tried to work on that for several years
shelved it and then they pivoted to what
was essentially a converted glue
dispensing robot and you know it was an
arm a robotic arm on a gantry with a
pipette at the end of it that sort of
replicated the steps that a lab
scientist does on the bench to test
blood and that was ended up being called
the Edison that it was it had a black
and white a sleek black and white case
but it really could only do one class of
tests known as the immunoassays and it
didn't do those tests even well and what
was the one test it could do for a they
were called the immunoassays tests that
use antibodies to bind to the substance
in the blood that you're trying to
measure so the the Edison was an
immunoassay machine but she was saying
even as you know work on the mini lab
the successor machine hadn't even
started she was telling Walgreens and
Safeway that she already had a machine
that could do everything and this was
part of the elaborate fraud that's
that's discussed you write about it in
the book we talked to some of the same
insiders that that are your sources here
too that essentially I'm gonna
interested in maybe donating a hundred
million dollars you would go into Theron
o--'s headquarters and they would say oh
come right here they would take your
blood they would put it in a little
cartridge into the Edison and then they
would into the mini lab they would show
investors the mini lab not even the
Edison that was in the lab but the mini
lab which was but enough malfunctioning
prototype yeah and so now let's take you
up to the business offices and have
lunch and waiting on you and then is
Doug Mackey
sat on 60 minutes they would then pull
the cartridge out and then actually have
scientists tested by hand it's never
worked that's right and then so then
when the investor would come back down
they would hand them test results and as
one mention to me usually though someone
in business affairs signed off and if it
was anything that looked bad they would
just kind of cross it off to it was
edited it was a fake it was a
bait-and-switch
and in fact Tyler Schultz who I later
revealed was one of my confidential
sources the grandson of George Schultz
was stymied in in in trying to call his
grandfather
attention to the fact that it was a
fraud by the fact that George had
experienced one of those fake demos and
he said I've done it I've seen the
machine I've its test its tested my
blood the results were accurate so Tyler
you're wrong I saw it with my own eyes
but he hadn't seen it he'd seen the the
fake demo the fake demo
the other interesting thing you reveal
in your book and I thought this was
relevant because someone said did the
media miss this story early on why did
everyone believe what was going on was
this fraud and part of the fraud was she
had two laboratories right there was and
so she was able to deceive regulators as
wrote to there was something called
Normandie right where they were doing
all of the futuristic type stuff where
they were gonna storm the beach of
Medicine right but which also mainly was
hacked Siemens machines that they had
repurposed for small samples not
innovation but as you point out in your
book that was like downstairs downstairs
and no windows - then there was what's
called Jurassic Park Jurassic Park
meaning older stuff up there but it was
one that the cameras went in and that
they let the investors in etc especially
Jurassic Park was where they showed the
inspectors they said see we have a lab
with regular commercial machines and we
have a lab director and that's what the
the inspectors the CLIA inspectors who
represent one of the health regulators
saw and and so they didn't even see the
lab downstairs and those Edison machines
that didn't work well and those siemens
machines that were hacked they didn't
even see that room so so regulators were
lied to
what's the future like for Elizabeth
Holmes she is still CEO right the
company is virtually bankrupt it's
amazing she's still CEO the the company
is still going concern for now but she
just laid off another hundred employees
last month so they had counts down to
about 20 people and she wrote an email
to investors in which she said that the
the company would probably be liquidated
and its assets seized and liquidated by
a private equity fund by the summer
before then or possibly after then I
expect to see an announcement from the
Justice Department the US Attorney's
Office in San Francisco has been
conducting a criminal investigation for
more than two years now and I'm told by
sources that that investigation is close
to drawing to a close and that
indictments are just
possibility any day now your book is
being made into a movie that's right and
and who will play Elizabeth Holmes
Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence and
who's writing the screenplay
Vanessa Taylor who co-wrote the
screenplay for the best picture a pod
shape of water wow that's pretty good to
get someone who just won Best Picture
right no it's a great combination of
talent and directed by Adam McKay who
did the big short so Hollywood's
interested in this story as well right I
think it's a story that could make a
good movie yeah well it makes a great
book John Kerry Roux thank you it's been
nice to talk to you over the years your
reporting is really terrific thanks very
much for having me thank you